so you must love dancing ma because we
got a video you and Patrick Wilson
dancing so wait here's the here there
you go there you go and then watch and
and he went straight up 90s like he
running
man do you love dancing oh yeah me too
it feels good we invented the hoola yeah
oh that's true okay well like shaking it
you know me we just invented having good
time in a bar that's what Texans did
good um so I heard that you were jealous
of Patrick cuz he got to eat a ton cuz
he had to gain weight for the roll and
you were trying to stay lean I heard
that you had to watch him eat a lot of
stuff but he had a he had to get slim
too he looks beautiful on this one he
got a little grumpy too yeah when you're
star yeah when you're starving yourself
to like yeah well I mean you're not
getting to eat like now I'm eating pasta
every me it feels good yeah yeah yeah
this is I'm getting ready for Minecraft
you know what I mean I got I got to let
this slip down into here
so it's different season I my God got to
keep warm for the winter um um here's a
behind the scenes look at Jason training
for the movie This is actually rad
watch I would so this is this is like
the creature that you just saw me on
right here yeah it's just we found this
in my phone but it's just me
me so what
what what training was that
for well that's how you go faster okay
so if you want the animal to go faster
you you got to really go okay I just you
have to slow it down
[Music]
yeah cuz there's no steering wheel look
like a different kind of training is all
I'm saying no there was a really awesome
Aquaman suit in this one I like this one
did you like that transition for
daytime look I didn't know how to segue
um so I so no you do you have a you have
a really cool suit for this one I like
this one yeah do you feel powerful in
that I do I would feel really cool I do
you know what's really fun is you're
talking to someone you'll be onet with
one of the grips and and then you have
to go put the suit on you come back 15
minutes later and you're like hey what's
up Bob and he's they're just like
they're intimidated yeah cuz you got the
eyes in and like the hair and the the
body yeah you're a lot bigger than what
you were 15 minutes ago yeah I'd be
scared to that
[Music]
[Applause]
guy thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home